hey how you doing
come on in
yeah yeah joey's in the back
hi welcome to uncle joey's
how about a drink to start off with
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 20th of december
it's the last week before santa shows up
let's give it a good [__] week the
joint is brought to you by blue chew
forget diamonds and cars and flowers
give your girl what she really wants for
christmas a good [__] dicken you know
what i'm saying everybody wants a good
stab and you don't have to put a bow on
it that's the beautiful thing about it
listen
maybe you don't have vd maybe you do
maybe you just want to perform like a
savage
blue chew is for you
blue chew is online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cyalis at a fraction of the
cost you can take them anytime day or
night the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved you'll
receive your prescription within days
you know what what that means it's time
to sling dick the best part is it's all
online no doctors visits no pharmacy no
[__] judgment it ships right to your
door in a discreet little package and
not even the mailman knows bluetooth
tablets are made in the u.s of a why
because we're all about the dick here in
the us of a it's way cheaper than a
pharmacy
and
if you can't perform no big deal don't
be ashamed i got problems too that's why
i got [__] blue true i pop one of
those blue pills i chomp down it and
next thing you know i'm slinging dick
with confidence and that's what we'll
all need sometimes you just need a
little confident and that's where blue
chew [__] comes in they're tremendous
and
listen go to bluetooth.com right now
look at the ad it's a lady [__]
walking the streets crazy why that's
what blue chew does it gives you the
dick to drive them [__] crazy so try
bluetooth today with promo code joey
j-o-e-y and just pay five dollars for
shipping joey how are you gonna do five
hours for shipping that's what happens
today with blue chew so that's
bluetooth.com promo code joey to receive
your first month free and as usual i
want to thank bluetooth for sponsoring
the joint to helping our young men by
slinging dick with three hands usa blue
chew
the joint is also brought to you by on
it listen
you want to start 2022 on the right
[__] foot
and alpha brain
is waiting for you they got the regular
alpha brain and we've got this beautiful
black [__] label and they don't
stop there i love the shroom tech i love
the new mood i love the mct oil listen
on it keeps showing up they're a
tremendous company why you're not doing
business with them it's beyond me start
with the alpha brain [__] black label
right now go on on it.com right now
order that black [__] label alpha
brain your mind will be firing on all
[__] cylinders i'm still little bots
but come january 1st i'm going on alpha
brain black label i'm starting to
[__] cycle and you're going to see me
pull out my hairs and sling dick then go
to honor.com right now press and co joey
or church
or joint whatever the [__] they got and
get 10 off delivered right to your
[__] beautiful house it's christmas
[__] and it's new year's eve
you want to start the year off like a
[__] savage start with on it get that
alpha brain
you'll thank me later cox and now
without further ado
let's get this podcast started it's
monday the 20th of december
if you ain't tip top magoo
go back to bed why waste people's time
let's get this [__] started
come on
to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here for another episode of
the joint it's monday the 20th we're
almost out of this [__] rotten year
you know some guy was telling me today
at cvs he goes yeah you know you're
going to have a bad year
when you're in the hospital january 1st
and i was like you know what
i was in the hospital january 4th
to the [__] 5th so i started the year
off with [__] needles and
ivs and you know
then that when you get the knee surgery
you're all [__] doped up in bed they
come get you and they go listen we got
to teach you how to walk in and out of a
car did i need that in my [__] life
january 4th i couldn't walk blood was
coming out of my [__] knee then i got
home
and um my wife is upstairs and i'm like
i need to get [__] high i forgot to
tell you guys about this and i [__]
went out in the garage at two in the
morning with a pipe and i fell
i just killed over on my knee and i'm
down on the floor yelling for my [__]
wife she didn't hear me for a half hour
i was in that garage freezing my ass off
yelling upstairs she came down it's like
what the [__] is wrong with you so
that's how i started off the [__]
year and then the pain pills took me to
[__] egypt those things are the worst
things that they ever gave anybody they
put me into a [__] depression
mixed with the [__] xanax i was taken
for the insur uh anxiety i was [__] up
guys and it just happens you know i've
been writing this book for the last
[__] year and what i've come up with
from this book we're on chapter we just
quit cocaine
and uh
we're about to go into 2008 and all that
stuff and it's it's it's weird that what
i've learned about myself from this
[__] book is that
i started over 18 000 times in my life
like i had to start over all the time i
am the king of [__] starting over
that's like a [__] gift
that i didn't even know i had i read
this i read the chapters like a week ago
and i'm like
it's the same story over and over of
your life of me doing something going
for a year or two and then crashing and
[__] up and then it takes another
year to get back on your feet six months
but it's a plan it's a [__] plan and
if you stick to the plan
you cannot lose you know somebody said
to me that i got an email
from a parent
a [__] parent
sent me a twitter [__] email
their son
uh
had to go to rehab you know and he
contacted me about a year ago and he
said he was honest with me he said he
didn't really like my comedy
but uh
that
he liked what my stance was and what i
had done he goes you know i used to one
thing i missed from the road i swear to
god
the
thing that bothers me the most about not
going on the road is talking to you guys
the podcast people and it would be
[__] great because
i'd be taking a picture with you
and they'd be all smiles they'd be happy
to see me whoever was there the
girlfriend taking care of taking a
picture of the boyfriend with me and
while we were taking the picture he
would kind of whisper
everybody did that to me and they would
say hey man we're having a good time and
[__] but
you helped me get off [__] this you
helped me get off that i'd listen to
what you said you know and and it's
crazy you know but it worked for me you
know
like i don't expect people i didn't
expect people to [__] quit smoking
cigarettes by getting an eight ball and
just sitting there [__] getting
tortured by themselves that was my
method because i like torturing myself
but
you know if they just reached out to me
and they said you have a
a gift of setting people and like a
weird like a
like they listen to you they pay
attention to you but the problem with
this kid was
his ghosts were just too strong like he
just lost it they had to put him in like
a two-year [__] rehab for pills and
heroin the whole thing so that's why she
reached out to me to just say i wouldn't
be hearing from him for a while
uh she gave me an address where his
rehab was in indiana they sent them to
some [__]
and i'm gonna write him a [__] letter
in there just for christmas it's just a
nice thing to do over the holidays write
somebody a letter that's in rehab
[__] thinking his world is about to
end and he doesn't know his world's
about to [__] start like that's what
people don't really understand
especially with drugs like you sit there
and you're like when am i going to get
off these things how much longer am i
going to do this for
and you're like you know what i'm not
even going to quit because i can't even
imagine
being without that stuff let me tell you
something
when i always said that to myself like
when i say that to myself that's a
motivating sentence for a guy like me
like i'm like you know what man
it's time i [__] clean up this drug
like and that and i've done that
listen i did it with the [__] valium
in 91 i did it with the [__] coke i
did it with the [__] reefer when i
went to prison you know you have to stop
you have to just stop but in the back of
your mind
you're like i can never do that and
that's the same thing about life i don't
know what
that correlation is that we
think of something like stand up i
remember being in 1993
and being in my little [__] rocky
apartment in uh boulder with [__] fat
tire
and i had a lettuce in my refrigerator
you know
being broke and watching guys like bill
hicks
watching all these [__] comics and
going
like to myself like even though
all day i've been pumping myself up to
myself just going i don't know why
you're doing this
you're never gonna [__] do anything
with your life i got so sick of hearing
that from myself
that those when i would put myself down
i would motivate myself it would
motivate me to [__] go you know what
that's a shitty sentence to say to
yourself
that i can never i don't think i could
ever [__] accomplish that that is the
shittiest thing
you could say to yourself because either
you
go to sleep when you say that to
yourself you're usually thinking about
that at night when you had a bad day
you're like maybe i'll just go to sleep
whatever or
you [__] go you know what
look what i just said
that's my mindset i gotta switch my
[__] mindset
that's what it is half the [__] time
hey listen i was lost
in march guys i was lost i i know i did
the podcast i know
it was a it was a rough podcast to
listen to i knew those days were
hard and i thank you for staying or i
thank you for leaving i would have left
myself
but i'm happy that it happened to show
you guys
that i could [__]
i could get out of any [__] dilemma
just give me a day to think about how i
can get a dilemma and i'm the king of
that [__] i'm like a fixer in my own
[__] head in march when i found out
you know i didn't know what was going on
i just knew i didn't feel [__] good
i knew i had been to the hospital a
couple times i knew something was going
on with my body
so i never cop to the i didn't think it
was the xanax i never thought it could
be the [__] xanax i didn't know what
was giving me anxiety so right away i
thought i had a mental health issue that
sucks
when you sit there and go i got a mental
health issue that sucks
because for years you've been calling
people retards
and [__]
stupid [__] and now
you got a mental health you know how
hard it made you know how hard it was
for me to come clean with that to you
guys
really hard but i didn't give a [__]
i didn't give a [__] at all because i
wanted you to i wanted to see
you guys
watch me come back
it was interesting to even watch me come
back i journaled it you know i [__] i
weighed myself i checked my pulse every
[__] day my oxygen levels i mean i
was on a roll i was experimenting you
know you go on these [__] uh
websites to help you with the benzo [__]
and they [__] tell you what to take
let me tell you something all the [__]
they tell you to take
sparks up that feeling of your heart
beating and all that stuff and i'd be
great till about one o'clock i started
taking the only thing that helped me the
truth calm myself down was on its
product a new mood
that slowed me down at night i just
finished the [__] bottle and put
another one out there
uh
safe
and calm calm and calm support calm
support all these [__] tablets i got
everything in them gabba the whole
[__] thing they jolt you up a little
bit but then they come back and calm you
to [__] down and it replenishes your
gaba that's what was wrong i i read up
on it when you [__] take those pills
they don't let the gaba receptors
[__] send signals so who the [__]
knows the brain is a [__] monster of
a [__] machine
and it doesn't send signals or whatever
and that's why it shocked my central
nervous system
when i heard it shocked my central
nervous system there's only one thing
that brings your central nervous system
back quickly
dead squats deadlifts deadlifts
i was doing dead lifts like a
[__] two days a week two and a
quarter 250 i would start with low reps
and then help him up and i'll tell you i
would do those things i could feel
myself getting zapped when i would put
the [__] weight down i would walk
around i'd see little [__] spots in
the air i swear to god it was like i got
knocked out but i didn't give a [__]
i kept going on it because i read those
things those benzo websites and those
benzo [__] where everybody talks and
i gotta be honest with you
everybody has a different struggle it
hits everybody differently
but although the one thing i saw that
was consistent with these [__] people
were that they had a hard time waking up
you know i read i
everybody said it was hard to get out of
bed it was hard to walk it was hard i
was like [__] that i'm getting the [__]
up i got up right from the bed straight
into the shower i take my little avon
pad wipe all the [__] spanish grease
off my face and off my neck i don't like
people's necks i'm a big problem with
[__] necks that's what the main stink
comes out that's why i always [__]
i got these little avon pads my sister
gives me she's like a big shot for avon
and these are my lisa she's [__]
great she's got these uh little pads
the best ones i've ever used look at my
skin look at my face i got no [__]
dirt on there there's no more zits i
gotta sit over here and i got a little
zit down here from [__] shaving look
at this little third eye over here but i
[__] put my little thing i jump in
the shower i brush my deet a little
listerine
and i would [__] eat breakfast they
said you won't feel like eating and the
first thing i would do was walk around
the neighborhood just to get my heart
going and then i would walk down to the
[__] gym the gym's like a block from
me so i would walk to the gym just
to get the [__] wilderness i had my
own rehab
did you know that i prepared my own
rehab this summer like i didn't go up
north i didn't do [__] every day my job
every day was to get
healthy and get through this [__]
thing and i was not gonna sit in the
[__] house like an idiot sitting here
feeling sorry for myself so that's why i
went to the pool remember i talked about
the pool all the time i would go to the
pool and the first thing i do at the
pool is take off my socks
and with my fungi toenail i [__]
both feet are all fungi up oh my god
i got to do something about the fungi on
my toenail the t3e is working that's
another thing i did this year i started
tea tree therapy january 1st every day
when you get out of the shower you rub
tea tree oil on your [__] toes and
you try to [__] keep your nails clean
and you chop them so you can put the tea
tree all under the nail so it eliminates
all that [__] fungus trust me i don't
like getting rid of that fungus that
fungus is one of my hobbies i have a
little toe on my lid on my right foot
that the nail looks like it's connected
to the [__] toe right it's disgusting
it looks like one big piece but it's
filled with fungi so every week like one
night a week when i get nice and high at
night i get the [__] uh i get the
[__] nail clip and i cut in that
[__] and let me tell you
something every time you cut the nail
smoke comes out of it it's tremendous
when i cut it just goes poof a little
bit of smoke comes out and then i get
the grind and i go in there with that
[__] grind and i get like two grams
of powder a tote of toe jam dust from my
[__] big toenail my little toenail i
don't even know i'm telling you my
deepest secrets but who gives a [__]
it's december 20th we got to open up the
[__] valve [__] people are
going to go into a depression mode
pretty soon i got to keep you
[__] intact
so let's keep talking about the fungi
toenails so it's tremendous i [__]
buff them both out i wear my mask
because i don't want that dust to go on
my [__] face because
sometimes when i
polish my [__] toenail with the
the spinner the [__] dust gets all
over the place i don't see it till the
next day i think i'm just it's just
falling by my foot i just i hold my foot
sometimes and i just watch the toenail
dust
gather on my foot like a gram
i [__] i put it between my fingers
and i smell and i think ali i'm like
[__] lee smoked that [__]
well we both smoked it i just recovered
from that i had a [__] molar that had
a [__] toe jam in it from [__] my
toenail but anyway i don't know what the
[__] i was talking about here with the
toenails what i was trying to say was
that it's been a [__] hell of a year
i'm happy it's [__] over but guess
what i [__] stood up to this
[__] year and i was like you
ain't taking me down [__] there's
no way dog
i wish i could tell you
how bad i felt inside like you don't
know what it's like to talk to somebody
on the street you haven't seen for a
while and your heart's just beating
while you're talking to that person
you're like why am i [__] running
while i'm standing here talking to this
poor best i mean it was terrible so
that's why i would look at i couldn't
even make eye contact with people
because i was thinking i was gonna die
on the [__] spot you don't know what
that's like
i'm trying to hydrate [__] give
me a breather here i know you guys get
mad when i drink water don't drink water
on the mic what do you want me to do sit
here and talk for [__] an hour with
no [__] water don't use a water
bottle yeah don't use a water listen i i
i know these things make noise i know
they're [__] up
but what am i gonna do put my water in
the canteen so you guys don't hear the
bottle get a grip we're all [__]
family here it's monday you know what
i'm saying why [__] around you've had
worse [__] noises in your goddamn
life but i'm happy it's all over listen
the last month
my job has been i know where i stand i
know where i stand
i feel good i'm ready but i'm still
feeling a little you know not a hundred
percent i'm at like 90 [__] four or
something like that
my job since the last month was just get
ready for 2022 and what i wanted to do i
was just telling mike
i was thinking of leaving uh next week
but i think i'm gonna push it back
stay in town i got some calls out to
offices uh like maybe two people calling
me back i think i had an appointment
wednesday to look at an office
about
three miles from here or some [__] just
take a look at it you know i don't know
i want to make a lot of changes i i got
rid of some people out of my life you
know that were just
wasting [__] time while they're
sitting there
while they're sitting there so i
switched governments i'm still working
with the ice cream shop [__] uh
everything's solid there all i've been
doing the last couple weeks like i said
it's just getting ready for the 2022.
that's it what i'm going to do in 2022
we got to hand the book in march
so we got another three months of work
in the book and i think the last three
months will be a little busier because
they'll just be rewrite so i'm busy with
that i'm also you know going back to
jiu-jitsu and i'm having a great time in
there and i tell you what thank god i
did that i'm grateful that i did
three things for myself i'm grateful
that i
read the taper and
stuck to it to the [__] t
i'm very happy i went back to
acupuncture i think acupuncture had
something to do with it i've been going
there for 14 [__] years to
acupuncture so once you take it out of
your life for a year i'm sure that it
went back to where i lived before who
the [__] knows
and i'm really happy
i'm very happy that i got my balls
and my anxiety in check
and i walked into that jiu jitsu thing
because i got to be honest here
it's the best thing i've did since i've
been here
and i knew when i walked in there for my
first private that as i was walking out
i told him i said you have no idea how
good i feel right now for coming
and getting this over with because
nothing bothers me more than being
[__] scared
nothing
for the first time my life
i was really [__] scared last year i
gotta be honest with you guys i
i didn't think i was gonna make it back
i wasn't able to think
i wasn't able to go out of a realm i
mean i was searching for words i
couldn't i couldn't find them you don't
know what
when you have a machine gun mine
like the one i have my thoughts always
getting popped into it
and all of a sudden you don't have that
no more
you start doubting yourself
i was really doubting myself i remember
that i started doing stand-up like in
february right after the surgery down at
uncle vinnie's and
the more i went down there
i found out that i just that's the only
reason why i stopped going uncle
vinnie's because i couldn't give a
hundred percent
i couldn't feel
like i gave i could give 100 i couldn't
say that at the time because i was kind
of ashamed of what i was going through
but after i figured out how to tackle
this [__] there's no shame it's over
we're on a [__] straight path to make
it back to [__] health and that's
what i knew but that's the only reason i
stopped going uncle vinnie's i love that
[__] club that's one of my favorite
clubs in the world it was just that
i wasn't doing anybody any good i was
going down there with the same old
[__] you know how hard
you know how bad it is for me to use the
same jokes
do you know where that puts my head to
go out there for four weeks in a row
and use the same jokes and i wasn't able
to write do you know what that puts me
that puts me in a bad [__] position
because there's one thing in this life i
always listen
in comedy you're gonna have good sets
and bad sets and i know that
and in podcasting you're gonna have good
sets and bad sets when you're [__]
somebody up the ass you have good nights
and bad nights right you're [__]
somebody you come quick and you don't
know what it was and you start blaming
your [__] high blood pressure or your
[__] uh ear medication you know we
can't score a hundred percent all the
time and i've come to grips with that
and i've had to accept that but
i
didn't do well on stage for so long
that when i had a chance when you guys
gave me a chance to perform
i had to rise to the [__] occasion
and i got to be honest here i don't like
bombing i know i lied to you guys that
[__] uh you need to get bombed you
need to bomb from time to time it builds
character and all that [__] i didn't
like bombing
i didn't like bombing i understood it
and i know where it came from and i knew
it was lack of preparation your head's
not in the right place but let me tell
you something guys
when you pay 25 to come see me i can't
have that
i can't have that hiccup that's the
that's what i've told myself i can't
have that hiccup and i learned that from
joe rogan joe rogan has a great line
something about mickey mantle
they asked him you know why do you
always do this every night and he goes
because i never want to cheat the people
out of you know they paid for a [__]
seat to come and watch me play baseball
and that's that's how i felt when i took
a bomb or i didn't do it let me tell you
something
i am still
still embarrassed about the bombing i
had in [__] new orleans two years ago
do you know that still haunts me to
today and i tell you what i did
they made a sign for me
of june 9th i was in new orleans i hung
it in my bathroom for a reason
because i'm always in the bathroom
taking a [__] and you just sit there
it's not like i got magazines or i got a
tv in there i just go in there and work
the mind a little bit but when i take a
[__] i look at that sign
i look at that sign as a reminder of the
bombing i did in new orleans and a lot
of you guys went to that show and you're
like joey you didn't bomb
i didn't bomb to you guys but i bombed
personally and i knew that
and as long as i said racist jokes
it was just not me that night it was
just not me and it happens then that
night was the night that we [__] got
stuck and
saying uh
me and steve simone got stuck in new
orleans because the planes were [__]
up in atlanta and i had to reschedule
the tabernacle theater whatever that was
but i never forgot that
i never ever forgot that bomb he was one
of the most embarrassing bombings and
then i went outside and had to talk to
people and that was even more [__]
embarrassing nobody came up to me that
night and said i helped him out either
it was just a cold brutal [__] night
i remember going back to my hotel and
going dog if i want to raise this
bar up i got to come a little bit more
[__] correct and i did i i took care
of the situation i did a great show in
vegas i had
five great shows and [__] uh
in uh
tempe you know before the [__]
pandemic hit i was doing kick ass shows
at the store i had my material tight i
had never been that tight as i was
before the [__] pandemic
when i [__] stopped doing comedy on
march 2nd or whatever the [__] was my
last time on stage
i was pissed because i was ready to
shoot a special i was ready to do a
thousand things before the [__]
pandemic started but so were a lot of
people woe is me so were a lot of people
[__] joey get your [__] together this
ruined a lot of [__] for [__] people
you know people didn't know how to act
after that look what's going on in the
[__] world today people getting
stabbed every day in the city people
being rude you know i was talking to
somebody online the other day and i and
i said this like a guy
and me were going back and forth
just the guy i talked all the time leon
and we were talking about
the behavior on the internet the last
year
real quick i hate to interrupt the
podcast but the joint is sponsored by
better help online therapy listen better
help wants you to know that truth about
some stigmas around mental health i was
kind of ashamed when i had a little
mental health problem but you know what
i'm it took care of my itself dana
at better health did a great job many
people think therapy is for so-called
crazy people i'm crazy but i ain't that
crazy but therapy doesn't mean
something's wrong with you it means you
recognize that we're all humans and that
we all have emotions and you need to
learn to [__] control them and not
avoid them therapy is a tool to utilize
before things get worse i didn't do that
that's why i got what i got that whole
year of high anxiety don't wait till the
anxiety is unbearable the insomnia is
unbearable don't let that pain hit you
anymore better help is customized
customized online therapy they're going
to offer you video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist if you
don't want to see anybody that's fine
too they'll turn the camera off it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you get start communicating
with your therapist in less than 48
hours i had my therapy session this
morning with dana and i'm feeling tip
top magoo give it a try and see why over
2 million people have used better help
online therapy if you go looking for a
therapist right now or a psychiatrist
you're not going to get any help and
they're going to they're going to go on
camera anyway you still got to pay 400.
forget that contact betterhelp.com
they're going to take care and what i'm
gonna do for you is for the joint
listeners you get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com
with slash diaz that's what i want you
to press in that's betterhelp.com
diaz better help
t t e r e h e l p
dot com and put in code diaz take
control of your life
it's a new year and you want to be
rocking start with better help remember
diaz and betterhelp.com
back to the podcast
it's just been [__] brutal
the things people say to people i read
not my comments but sometimes i read
other people's comments
just to see you know they posted
something i want to see what people's
reaction is
it's not good out there people's hearts
are not in the right place not their
mind
it's their heart because the heart goes
to the mind and tells you hey
it's a beautiful day it's a sunny day
sunny day sunny day but i don't know
what the [__] is going on i see i see
the rudeness online
listen i'm to the point i've been online
for so long you want to say something to
me that's fine sometimes i say your
mother sucks dick
sometimes i look at you and i say i say
a prayer for you because you're a
[__] [__] and you don't know where
the [__] you're coming from a couple
weeks ago we did a manscape video in my
bathroom
[Music]
i put the video up on instagram
i had like two guys going joey clean
your shower
clean like that's what you saw in that
video
that's what you saw i'm over there
talking about you know cutting your
balls hair and sprinkling [__]
reviver in your [__] from manscape
and what you got to say to me
is that i got to clean my shower and let
me tell you something i actually got up
went and looked at the shower and i go
this ain't nobody uses the shower you
[__] jerk off it's a downstairs
bathroom that's why it's my personal
[__] [__] been there nobody uses that
bathroom mike p's in there my wife don't
even use that bathroom nobody goes in
there it's just solo it's just me nobody
showers in there i got a ton of [__]
like if you come over [__] nut i'll have
you take a shower in my shower
everything's in there shampoo a loofah
everything's in there nobody uses that
[__] it's kind of gonna let's take an
electronic shower
you gotta press buttons it's no turners
and [__] so you don't know what i don't
know what the yeah she put it down here
for a daughter i guess her daughter
lived in this room and in that bathroom
her daughter but the [__] shower is
tremendous but that's what you came up
with
that i didn't clean my bathroom
dog this house is [__] clean as can
be my wife cleans this hike helper the
only thing that's dirty in this house is
that [__] toilet down here because i
dumped some tremendous shits in there i
mean
22 inches
dark brown you know a couple pieces of
granola in there i go deep in that
[__] bathroom the other day there was
a skid mark in there how to chisel it
with a [__] chisel and it had
plastered itself into the it was like a
skid mark just going straight into the
[__] toilet just the piece of [__]
just landed on me i don't put my balls
under the toilet i haven't put my my
dick in a toilet in years i put my dick
outside the toilet i hold my balls while
i'm [__] i massage them i warm them
i put a little manscape revive on them
and i just [__] work them you know
i'm saying that that [__] you don't want
that [__] smell to creep into your nut
sack so that's why i get the little
reviver i rub my balls but my [__]
doesn't go in the water i don't like
water hitting my ass i don't know where
i stand so i like to [__] two or three
inches up let it go down let it go
downhill so at least i i piss on it and
it explodes and it smells like a [__]
dead body but
that's what i do guys when i'm [__]
lonely and bored i know i'm 58 going on
[__] five i know how to have a
good time by myself
these [__] don't have a good
time by themselves you gotta take a [__]
and pee on it i do it i do a ton of
experiments back there in that bathroom
i try shave my balls with manscape i
[__] charge up in fact you got to fix
that [__] thing that weed map sent me
today that little vaporizer yeah i want
to start smoking with the little
vaporizer
i was shot just try it now i've been
charging it for the last [__] two
weeks if you take a hit off that you'll
electrocute yourself i also got this
[__] little pen
from uh i gotta be honest i'm not a
vaper pen guy
but
i [__] uh abx sent me some vaper pens
i gave a couple to mike
and they only sent me one little thing i
was gonna give that to mike i thought
they were gonna send me a couple of them
but they sent me only one battery the
battery that you smoke uh live resin
from
no you don't even twist it you just snap
it on
it's [__] tremendous it's [__]
tremendous and it kicks like a [__]
mule sometimes i don't want to go
outside it's cold that night i got my
pajamas
i just hit that a little bit and i
[__] uh sit down here watch whatever
i'm watching or write
but i don't want to go outside like last
night i went outside like no saturday
night for the ufc
i must have gone outside four nights
that's how i know i'm back because i was
just smoking one joint at night like at
10 o'clock that was the rule
now i'm starting a little earlier like
now i've been starting like at a quarter
eighth
and i got some good [__] the other day
right from jersey did i tell you that
mike i got some nice [__] reef i'll
give you a little piece of this i didn't
get a lot of it
but uh
it was pretty [__] good
yeah i was pretty listen guys i'm you
know
i've been smoking that cali [__] that
zeky [__] for [__] years so
it was tough for me to let that go but i
actually told them i said you know what
guys
i gotta stop you gotta stop
you know like i would have my friends go
out or whatever and then they come back
you know and they bring me like [__]
that they got over there and i said you
know what mike my friend
was going to la tuesday and he asked me
last week do you want me to bring you
something back i'm going to stop by the
ice cream shop
i said no
because it's just
guys you know what it's like i don't
want to run out
you know you can't you're always looking
at your weed i was like [__] this i
can't
keep depending on california you know
i've been here 15 months already it's
time for me to get a [__] connection
and somebody on patreon one of the dudes
on patreon my man our pen
turned me on to this [__] uh weed
delivery service right here in jersey i
go online i order it the night before
like if i order tonight
i have the weed here at 11 o'clock
tomorrow morning cute little
african-american chick came over the
other day dropped it off i asked her in
like i didn't even know she was coming i
thought she was coming at one and she
ended up coming like 11 30. i was
downstairs writing and i heard the
doorbell almost shipped my pants my wife
was home i looked at the door from
downstairs it was an african-american
chick i go who the [__] i go oh my weed
is here so i went up the stairs i opened
the door what's happening beautiful
she's like oh what's going on uncle joey
i said come on in
she smelled [__] great i went
downstairs i got her money i tipped you
you could tip on the [__] app but i
always tip them just for coming over
here they bring it right to the [__]
house you can't lose only in [__] job
well they got them everywhere who am i
kidding but i like this service in
jersey they got edibles
they got packwoods you know they got
some great [__] reefer
it's donation
like only like that's the scam that you
have to do or it's not really a scam
that's the way you have to do the
service it's donation only
uh they have different packages like
diamond platinum
silver gold you know and it works it
[__] works
and so what i'm smoking reefer that's a
little notch down this last weed i got
from them
holy [__]
it was a little extra it was 250 for the
half ounce
but i enjoy it i don't have to bother
them i don't have to bother my friends i
don't have to [__] you know i just i
just feel creepy after a while i'm just
putting
it's like you know what i don't need to
go through all this and put people
through this
i don't want to put somebody through
this they get stopped at an airport they
come back like joey you [__] it let me
learn where to get some weed and jersey
it's not like i'm smoking like in cali
i'm not smoking with three hands anymore
i mean it's right i'll tell you one
thing that came out of this year
i don't smoke in the daytime no more and
i got to be honest with you
i kind of like it it's nice it's a nice
[__] feeling man
it's a bit much i was getting high
[__] all day in l.a and i knew it had
to change i knew my sound i don't even
have that whistle in my [__] voice
anymore have you noticed that the
[__] uh
the little whatever what do they call
that disease when you smoke cigarettes
i got that [__] i had the beginnings
emphysema yeah i got the beginnings of
it the last x-ray they did for me maybe
five years ago dr waxer told me because
you get the beginnings of emphysema i go
you don't think i know that i hear the
[__] whistle in my chest at night
when i'm [__] i should be snoring
it's like i swallowed a [__] kazoo
you gotta hear the [__] noises that
come out of my chest at night when i'm
[__] sleeping but
hey it's all a [__] part of
growing up man
i had another shock this weekend
thank you all you [__] for
reaching out
uh my little lulu died and the crazy
thing is she died a day
after the anniversary was super bad
super bad's anniversary
was friday the 17th and
lulu died saturday the 18th
it was rough at the house it was really
rough for my wife
my daughter hasn't put it together yet
like she just hasn't figured it out yet
we really kept it from her a little bit
was she tight with the cats
yes and no she comes down here a lot in
the mornings and plays with them she
brushes them and she watches tv before
she eats breakfast so
she came down this morning and she
didn't notice it i don't think she would
tell her during the week when things
slowed down a little bit my wife was
still crying this morning you know i
have another cat that's here with me
evie i don't even know i'm gonna do the
album of the week because she's so
heartbroken she just wants to sit close
to me and i'll tell you what between us
i hope she doesn't name me
she's got a couple days left too because
i had dead brothers i remember i have
this this family i've had
i've been dealing with this cat family
since 2004.
you know samurai [__] a lot of kittens
back there
that [__] left a legacy that was
untarnished i just found the video of
him i'm gonna put it up for you guys a
guy shot a video of me and samurai
walked right past us
and i'm like show this [__] i'm
like sammy sammy sammy would just look
at you
give me the finger
i'll give you the claw i swear to god
this [__] didn't he wouldn't
even take fancy feast
like you know how many times i brought
him all different types of food in fact
when they even brought him crab meat
he just [__] looked at me like [__]
you and you crab meat he refused that
[__] wanted nothing to do with
people so but
he gave birth to like 90 [__] kittens
and then he was killing them
and we couldn't have that and
you know we had their boys i had
from that cat
samurai i probably had
i had demi
harry
super bad was his son but halfway super
bad's mother her mother was [__] two
cats at the same time she was a dirty
[__] she was [__] the big black and
white cat
and samurai in fact they even fought to
like almost a death
samurai fought super bad's father almost
to the death there was a horrible
bang-up fight in my backyard no worries
but so we started with
super bad no
demi
harry
ally
who else was his [__]
kid
evie and lulu so we probably took about
six of their kids
lulu and evie had siamese colorings and
super bad
they were both in the same [__] womb
guys this is just tremendous she gave
birth to three siamese cats and one
black and white one
from the father from super bad's father
it was crazy it was a learning [__]
experience i did not know about i
learned so much
i like animals guys i'm [__] sorry i
like dogs i like cats i like birds i
don't like fidgets i don't like [__]
pigeons something like that but i like
[__] cats and dogs i
i honestly
i gotta be honest even when i'm i'm
writing this book i'm going to put this
in the book
i honestly think that
well i know for a fact
what brought me back all those years and
gave me the strength to
cancel the coke to stop doing coke was
these [__] cats i swear to god i
don't know what it was
i felt like a father i don't know if
that was it but little by little
i stopped snorting after i got these
cats and super bad was it you know when
i got so bad he was almost dead i made a
promise and that was it that was 14
[__] years ago
that was it that's how much these cats
meant to me you know
listen guys i lived in california i know
you guys uh
everybody in california has a support
animal i know you don't want to hear
this [__]
listen i don't like when people come on
a plane with a [__] cocker spaniel
and the thing is making noises you know
if a dog shits on a plane they have to
take the plane down
so every time i see a [__]
uh dog come on a plane i'm like if you
[__] [__] i would send them like
messages like how michael vick you you
[__] if you [__] take a [__] on
this plane and you make this because one
time they did that to me they had to
[__] clean the [__] plane so the
plane went down they had to take the
lady off with a [__] stupid dog clean
the [__] disinfect the plane i was two
hours [__] delayed because your
[__] service animal took a [__] on
the [__] on the plane here
it was horrible so every time i see a
[__] dog come on there
i'm like really lady but she always
brings like two or three dogs and she's
chatty as [__] so if you're scared of
something i'm not seeing it here all the
[__] people got service dogs always
chatting always talking you know don't
blame it on the [__] door all of a
sudden you're chatty because the [__]
dog is here so
like i kind of believed it i kind of
didn't i had a problem like 10 years ago
i was fainting
from the edibles and god knows what else
i was just fainting i had like three
faints in like a year and every time i
would faint i would i would feel it
coming on
i would run this when we lived in north
hollywood i would run to the [__] uh
chair that was next to the air
conditioner and i would rip my shirt off
rip my pants off and i would just sit
there [__] sweating with the [__]
you know like 50 degree air blowing on
me and i'd still be sweating profusely
and i had this cat
uh what was his name finney
finney would see me from a distance and
run over to me and jump on me
and i'd have no shirt on and he'd jump
on me and start clawing my chest and i'd
want to [__] choke him i was ready to
[__] punch him and i go
i know what this [__] is doing
he's trying to take my mind off whatever
i got going on
so i won't faint
he did that a couple times he saved my
life another time i banged my head in
the closet i was bleeding and he [__]
came and sat with me too because i don't
like blood i looked at my hand i was
bleeding i got a little [__] queasy
but
i figured out that this [__] was
just uh
taking my anxiety away
so when i went through all this [__]
last year i became tighter with these
[__] cats like i would pet them more
petting a cat relieves your anxiety
i don't know if you guys know that
petting a cat petting a dog playing with
a dog if you have a hang of anxiety run
right to your [__] cat or dog and see
what happens i if i would have put that
[__] together i would have never
taken those [__] xanax i would have
just petted my cat everywhere i would
have taken them i swear to god before
the [__] pandemic
i was thinking about making one of my
cats a service cat
because i was sick and tired of these
[__] dogs coming on
and nobody shows up with a [__] cat
and then people started showing up with
two or three dogs and i was like you
know what
if i come on here with a [__] cat
because everybody has their [__]
animal why should my cat stay home
these cats have all been my support
animal [__] 20 years now i really
feel that that when i got the cats in my
life when i put the cats in my life my
my house changed for the better i
started [__] with cats in maybe 2003
and in four years i got off coke i just
felt better i felt
like maybe i was a father again i would
buy them toys i would go to [__]
petco and buy them the stands you know
how many [__] stands i had in my own
when we moved from l.a no many stands i
threw away
i had one two
bro they were 200 a piece those stands
and i had them all over the place and
then i was thinking of
running the stand up in the wall yeah
because i talked to the guy he was going
to come over but it wasn't my house so i
had to take it down and [__] so i said
forget about i love my [__] cats and
i got entertained by them you know some
guy
hit me up this morning or two days ago
no yesterday because lulu died on
saturday and this guy hit me up on
patreon and he was talking about joey i
think it's time for you to get a dog i
said oh duh
duh you know but i got two cats still
you know i
i hate saying this in front of evie
but i don't give her another month
you know the broken artifact you know
her sister's gone her and her sister
were inseparable mike was saying that
the last two zooms we did the sisters
were in their little [__] pen
beating the [__] out of each other it
was tremendous but
yeah you could hear them on there
but they were tight they loved each
other and uh
it was really sad to see a [__] goal
you know
i could come on here and cry you know
listen i i been looking at her and
playing with her
for the last six months i knew her time
was gonna expire it was just i didn't
know when
i wish it wouldn't have happened before
the [__] holidays
it'll affect our home a little bit thank
god my wife's going away to see her
family and [__] and uh the holidays this
week but no this is going to be a little
rough thing for the house this week and
guys
it's all a part of [__] growing up
you know i was little down
saturday afternoon when my wife took her
because
they called and they said she's fine we
think it's diabetes
and then they went out and they told my
wife that no
her uh
her functions have given up her kidney
or her liver
something had given up they shut down so
my wife said she went in
i said goodbye she called me she took a
picture of her but she said by the time
they got to the hospital
every time my wife would pet her she
would turn around and hide i don't know
if you know that when cats
feel like they're going to die they
don't want to see
they don't want you to see them dying so
they hide
and she was already hiding i could tell
friday night something was up with her
because when i was petting a friday
night she was meowing loud
i had never heard a meow that loud
so something was giving up she was in
pain and uh
she's in a better [__] place guys you
know listen
animals come and go they become part of
your [__] family and it sucks when
they go but
it's some that i've been dealing with
for years remember i had 11 of these
[__] so
you know every time one died i lost a
little piece of me you know the one that
hurt the most for me was super bad
you know i always thought that after he
died
i i like just a little doubt in my head
that maybe i would do coke again but no
i never did i mean his love stuck
and uh
i'm happy i got to experience these guys
you know i grew up without cats i didn't
know what a [__] cat was
you know when i was a kid that you know
we threw [__] bottles at him or
whatever or [__] yelled at him
and then for years whenever i would go
to somebody's house who had a cat when
they jump on me and i'd pet him they'd
purr but the purring i thought with them
like growling i never owned the cat
so when you piss off a dog the dog goes
when you piss off a cat i don't know
what noise they make but they start
[__] uh purring and once they start
doing that [__] with threading i don't
know what they call kneeling whatever on
your leg i thought they were going to
attack me so i throw them off and the
owners would go what happened you know
the cat loves you and i'm like nah that
cat was sticking me with nails no that
means he loves you you know what [__]
that [__] nobody who loves you sticks
[__] nails into you so you know what
i'm saying that cat don't [__] love
me but little did i know that that's
part of that thing and now i got like uh
who used to need oh
the gray the the cat at night my night
cat the therapist
she [__] does that to me at night and
i gotta like sit there for [__] an
hour and let her do a thing
while uh she's getting ahead together
and you know even that with gray at
night
my day is complete i turn the tv over
you know they always say to turn your
appliances off don't watch it and that's
what i do at night i turn the tv off i
try to read it
uh
a [__] chapter of any book that i
have just a chapter
just a chapter and i've been getting
into led zeppelin again and to make it
[__] worse
that bob lolingis just sent me a new
biography that came out by led zeppelin
holy [__]
holy [__] you know bob lalingus has me
has been sending me zeppelin books
for years
he sent me the jimmy page book he sent
me the big led zeppelin book the
three-parter that's [__] huge
and now he sent me this new book i
should have brought in here to show you
guys a great christmas present
you know i was reading the one chapter
about leads up and i'll rap after this i
know i've been talking a little too much
today you're like joe you're giving me a
[__] ear beating today i know
i'm in a good mood i'm happy guys the
holidays are coming we get to spend time
with our families i got to spread the
[__] cheer
i know a lot of you [__] is a
tough time of the year for you but again
this is a tough time for me too it took
a couple years to adjust and i finally
did it my mother's gone my father's gone
i'm not gonna bring him back so i'm
gonna do sit like a [__] orphan on
christmas eve and cry no christmas is
the best time of the [__] year you
know what they're looking down on me
going what the [__] joey spark up that
christmas tree light that [__]
on fire
shoot that poison arrow through my heart
you [__]
listen i'm gonna make the best christmas
i can this year i was a little upset
that my wife and my daughter were
leaving me after christmas you know
they'll be back by new year's but i'm
like this is the time of the year for
this [__] go
jump on a plane [__] get covered
you know stand online for two hours you
know get abused at the [__] airport
be my guest if that's what you want to
do i'm gonna sit tight this holiday
season
enjoy what's going on here
have a great [__] time and just get
ready for 2022. i listen whether
with the cat without the cat without the
kids it's gonna be a great [__]
holiday let me tell you what else i'm
fired up about
i'm really fired up about 2022 guys and
i hope you guys are getting fired up in
fact tomorrow i'll start reading the art
of war i mean i'm getting ready i'm
getting i don't know what war is coming
up i don't know what we're gonna do i
have no i don't know what i'm doing this
year i'm gonna finish this [__] book
and i'd love to [__] uh
do a one-man show for years i tried to
do a one-man show i knew i had it in me
and i think that's the route to go i
still want to perform
but i think i would just want to tell
that story you know and uh
once we get the book ready
i'll just
rip out the [__] from the book once it's
finished and that's what we'll present
at the at the [__] one-man show
i think i'll do it towards the end of
the year it's going to take me some time
to write i've been already making notes
of what i want to say on it you know i
think it's going to be fun
i'm excited about it you know i'm just
going to take it right from the book so
once the book gets released it's the
book and the one-man show i'll do a
couple book signings you know i'm gonna
try to do my best guys but uh i'm just
excited for 2022. i'm not excited
for the surprises they're going to throw
on us
joy what are you talking about what
surprises i don't know
i don't know we might get a mandate here
in jersey we might get more vaccine
mandates
you know we could only put 600 in the
bank you know there's just so much
stupid [__] that i've been hearing
lately i don't even pay attention to it
because i gotta do what the [__] i do
you know what i'm saying i don't give a
[__] what they're doing that's fine what
they're doing but we're gonna do what we
do we can't have money in about i don't
even know all the [__] that's going on
it doesn't even matter to me but expect
a little [__] surprise next year i
don't know what it's going to be
i don't know if it's going to [__]
even affect us but
i'm just
letting you get prepared you know we got
mandates in new york shit's closing down
we got mandates in la now they put extra
mandates in l.a didn't they
because the numbers are high again we're
still safe here in jersey we still
don't have to wear a mask inside even
though the numbers are up you know
all i could say to you guys it's
this is the best time of the year i
cannot believe the [__]
you know that you're gonna be scared now
you're gonna go to a christmas party
that you might get sick
listen live your [__] life this thing
is here with us
and it's like my girl sandy sanati said
on [__] patreon she goes joey you
were right
me and my father got covered well guess
what
we're all gonna [__] get it but i'd
rather get it january 2nd
they get a december 22nd you know what
i'm saying so avoid christmas parties
avoid heavy breathers
and just uh
enjoy your [__] holiday guys because
it's going to be a great one i i just
feel it i feel it in my heart and in my
bones i've been down for so long for the
last year and a half between pandemics
knee surgeries moving that i'm ready for
my [__] life guys so uh
it's gonna be a great [__] week
that's all you need to [__] know from
your uncle joey thank you for watching
the show today thank you for all the
uh warm-hearted messages about lulu
she's in a better [__] place now now
i got to deal with my girl evie
as you can see we she was in here
earlier i picked her up and brought her
outside but she doesn't want to be alone
out there it's just an ugly reminder i
don't blame her you know so
she's sleeping she's out [__] cold
right now as out as she could be
and i love her to death thank you i have
a great [__] week
this is a great [__] day to get your
[__] together and remember you got four
more shoplifting days left right it's
the 20th or the 21st who gives a [__] i
love your [__] suckers with all my heart
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors jack i love you [__]
all right you [__] i love you
i know i was all over the place today
but who gives a [__] i'm so excited i
want to stab three [__] maybe
four i'm not sure yet anyway the joint
is brought to you by
better help listen
i've been with better help now for close
to six or seven months and i feel tipped
out my good you guys have seen my change
if you if you're struggling a little bit
you don't know who to talk to
better help is there they got a girl a
woman named dana who turned me to [__]
around i'm tip top magoo and i know you
feel a little apprehensive because
people think therapy is for so-called
crazy people i'm crazy but i'm not that
crazy you know how i know because better
helped help me out that therapy doesn't
mean there's something wrong with you it
means that you're recognizing
your own self your emotions and you're
learning to control them not avoid them
therapy is a tool to use before things
get worse don't be like your uncle joey
and let what happened march 2nd ruin you
i should have paid attention then but i
didn't don't wait till it gets
unbearable better help
is customized online
therapy they offer video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
you don't got to see nobody on camera if
you don't want to i felt the same way
when i started
it's much more affordable in person
therapy right now listen
therapists are busy psychiatrists are
busy they're still gonna put you on a
camera and charge you four bills that's
why you're gonna contact betterhelp.com
today it's much more affordable in
person therapy but there's not in person
therapy because everybody's scared and
you can start communicating with your
therapist in less than 24 hours that
means if you reach out today
you could be talking to somebody
wednesday and feel a lot better about
the holidays stop
feeling bad or stop thinking about what
you're thinking learn some coping skills
give
better help a try right now and see why
they've helped over two million people
all right just for the joint listeners
i'm gonna get you guys 10 off the first
month on betterhelp.com
use code diaz d i a z that's
betterhelp.com
diaz take control of your life and get
the help you deserve
with better help this joint is also
brought to you by on it listen they just
had a sale but don't worry about i'm
still going to take care
if you want to try that shroom taking
that alpha brain and that on it and the
electrode
electrolyte drink mix which is [__]
tremendous with sodium potassium and
magnesium go to honor.com listen if you
order the alpha brain and you don't like
it they'll give you your money back and
you can keep them snort them light them
on fire do what the [__] you want to do
and they even got something for memory
focus i'm looking at it right now i
drank one a couple weeks ago and i
forgot to tell you it's not bad the
tropical flavored alpha brain give it a
shot use code joey joint or church to
get 10 percent off
delivered right to your [__]
house the joint is also brought to you
by bluetooth listen forget about all
that fancy stuff you're thinking about
getting your girlfriend you're trying to
impress her you know what a woman really
wants a good stabbing for christmas and
then to wake up and see santa coming
down the chimney you want to give him a
good stabbing get some blue chew blue
chew is an online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra as
cialis at a fraction of the cost
listen you can take it any time
any place it takes about 40 minutes and
you're wrapping in your pants and the
process is simple you sign up at
bluechew.com
you talk to one of the licensed medical
providers it's easy once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days and the best part of it it's all
online nobody knows nothing who got no
doctor's office visit no pharmacy no
judgment it ships right to your door in
the discreet package not even the
mailman knows bluetooth tablets are made
in the u.s of a way cheaper than any
[__] pharmacy so do me a favor right
now if you order today you'll have them
for new year's eve
and who doesn't sling dick on new year's
eve you want to be prepared you want to
show up like a [__] marine so do me a
favor when you need extra confidence
it's time to perform blue chew is right
there it's like your big uncle they got
a special deal for you today that's what
i'm saying you want these for new year's
eve try bluetooth for free with promo
code joey j-o-e-y
just pay the fin five dollars for
shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month free as usual and i want to thank
bluechu for sponsoring the joint i want
to thank bluechu
i want to thank honett and i want to
thank better help for having our back
great services i love better help so do
yourself a favor [__] support our
sponsors i love you guys have a great
monday have a great week have a great
christmas week do all your holiday
shopping and i'll see you [__]
wednesday morning the 22nd tip top magoo
stay black
[Music]
you